we're moving on from the perimeter
circle and the perimeter because he
circles a special shape the perimeter of
a circle has a special name and started
to see circumference we had
circumference before and when we're
looking at circumference we learned that
if you know in a circle that's not bad
if you know the measurement from the
center of the circle if you go from the
center to anywhere on the circumference
right anywhere you like
we call that of course doesn't know the
radius very good the radius is the same
whichever direction you're pointing your
community Queen down up left right
anywhere question okay so I think if I
have it on the board it'll be great to
have you as well and you have drawn a
few circles so you can make slowly now
we remember right that if you know what
the radius is if you know what the
radius is that you can say this
circumference will be equal to that
radius times a special number what was a
special number yeah Nathan
yes editor okay we're going to have it
suit in there there's another number I
need as well as the to Adam hi pi PI
which is about 3.1 four months five nine
two yeah and so on it never stops if you
remember back to UM way back earlier the
year where will they get sense fantastic
we said that thirds were irrational
numbers right they go on they go on
forever and ever and ever and ever no
and they and they never repeat what pi
is even more special it's not even this
sir okay it's even more crazy than a
certain such a thing as possible okay
and just like I said it never appeared
goes on so we take two
and pi and then we multiplied by the
radius and that will give you
circumference that whole length around
the edges okay so we establish our when
you're going to use that fact today as
we think about area perimeter area
length area is very natural progression
so here we go we've got some circles how
are we going to work out the area of
these shapes they're weird
they're curvy and round right so it
doesn't quite follow the rules that we
use without other shapes
we'll give a suggestion don't you find
so you get the center so you want to say
and you find like the radius and then
you've got times the radius by PI and I
think you do that twice because you can
okay alright so so what we're getting
towards what you're what you're leaning
towards and we're going to establish is
just like a formula for circumference we
will establish a formula for area but
hold on to your hats I'm going to show
you how does the mathematicians have
done this ingenious thing and we've got
a few steps er to work out what this
formula which there's a few different
ways but I'm going to show you one of my
most favorite ones okay so here we go
you got your circles right got you so
good now I've done mine in colors
because this will make it more obvious
if you don't have any colors on you if
you maybe have like a blue pen and a red
pen that'll do as long as you can
distinguish what's going on okay now
what I'm going to do I'm going to do
this three times in sort of different
ways I've got this circle and so far I
have it in two halves okay now this is a
crucial step
do you remember of earlier up in the in
the topic we're looking at composite
shows what's a composite shame yeah
Nathan
more than one very good yeah it's a
shape that's made up of more than one
shape so for example this L block right
we don't have a formula we have a
formula for squares and a formula for
rectangles thank you and for we have all
kinds of shapes we don't have a formula
for ELLs but that's okay that's okay
what did we do to this thing in order to
work it out yeah even you put like a
phone Y down but you have to kind of do
it I can get your minds might not a very
good now is it yeah that's right okay so
in other words we're dividing up a shape
that we don't know whatever formula for
in two pieces that we do have formulas
for and that's exactly what we're going
to do here so here's the way I'm going
to begin I've got um I've got two halves
at the moment okay so it's like okay
this bit of this bit that's better right
I've broken down the problem a little
bit but I can go a little further I'm
going to take each of these halves and
divide them in half as well so now I
have quarters yeah so now if I take each
of these quadrants I can rearrange them
a little bit okay I'm going to rearrange
them in a certain way and we're going to
draw these underneath so we got a few
steps coming out uh sir um because
they're quarters by the way because
they're quarters these have special
names these quarters when your inner
circles anyone know starts with a Q as
well 10 quadrants very good it's we have
quadrants here I'm going to take each
one of my four quadrants and I'm going
to reassemble them right I'm gonna
reassemble them so that they fit
together like this okay now maybe your
brain is really out of the building to
see that you're like what how did that
work so let me try and help you because
I have had these colors for reason this
I hope makes it a little more obvious
yeah okay so think it's a blue tent let
me show you what I've done is I've taken
the orange half I've taken the black
half I've divided the rough
and then which way this way the four
quadrant its quadrant it's the same area
it's exactly the same area but I've
rearranged it